emergenza climatica riscaldamento
globale cambiamento climatico
siamo di fronte ad una delle più grandi
crisi sociali economiche ed ambientali
della nostra epoca
eppure pensiamo di essere in un grande
supermercato dove tutto è disponibile in
base al nostro bisogno desiderio ci
siamo forse dimenticati di essere su
questo pianeta
probabilmente quello che ci aspetta un
futuro molto incerto per noi e per le
nostre generazioni ma forse abbiamo
un'alternativa pensarci in relazione con
ciò che ci circonda
vi siete mai soffermati a pensare al
significato della parola ambiente
il termine ambiente deriva dal latino
ambiance participio presente del verbo
ambire nel significato di andare intorno
circondare personalmente ci ho messo un
po di tempo a comprendere davvero il
significato di questa parola non sono
mai stata né una grande attivista né una
grande ambientalista non sono vissuta in
campania e direttamente a contatto con
la natura
probabilmente la davo per scontato
pensavo che fosse tutto lì semplicemente
amia è limitata a disposizione ma forse
non è proprio questo è l'atteggiamento
che ci ha portati alla situazione
attuale il tema ambientale il
cambiamento climatico sembrano delle
tematiche nuove recenti soprattutto dopo
le manifestazioni nelle piazze di
centinaia di città hanno fatto sembrare
e urgente lo è sicuramente eppure il
cambio climatico e le sue conseguenze
negative non sono una novità sono nota
almeno dagli anni settanta quel momento
fu di grande fermento intellettuale
culturale in acqua il movimento hippy il
la lotta per i diritti civili per i
diritti delle donne
il movimento ambientalista così come lo
conosciamo oggi proprio in quegli anni
nacque anche il club di roma un circolo
di scienziati uomini di affari e
politici che commissionò alle mariti
negli stati uniti di fare una ricerca
per indagare quale sarebbe stato il
trend mondi
quale futuro analizzando alcuni fattori
come le risorse
il cibo la produzione la popolazione nel
1972 pubblicano il rapporto sui limiti
dello sviluppo
già allora in questo rapporto emersero
dei risultati abbastanza allarmanti si
vide che in base alla produzione al
consumo di quell'epoca e proiettandola
almeno fino al 2050 e analizzando anche
la crescita demografica che ci sarebbe
stata
le risorse sul nostro pianeta non
sarebbero state sufficienti per tutte
continuando a quel ritmo in un pianeta
finito
non possiamo avere risorse infinite
proprio lo scorso aprile si è sciolto
uno degli iceberg più grandi del mondo
la 68 in origine questa montagna di
ghiaccio misurava circa 6 mila
chilometri quadrati come la nostra
liguria e oggi ne rimane solo una
miriade di frammenti il mare continua a
innalzarsi le acque si acidificano
portando a una conseguente perdita di
biodiversità è sempre di più vivremo
degli eventi estremi come uragani
inondazioni
le cause di questo disastro ambientale
sono da trovare nelle attività umane che
sono state portate avanti almeno degli
ultimi 50 anni quindi l'utilizzo di
combustibili fossili di agricoltura
intensiva allevamenti intensivi
ma non solo il cambio climatico non si
limitano a si riduce ad essere un
problema strettamente ambientale ma è lo
specchio dei nostri di riso guai anzi
sociali già esistenti nel mondo quindi
porterà e sta già portando ad aumentare
quello che è il divario di classe la
povertà la violazione di diritti umani
vi porto un esempio
andiamo al lago ciad nella parte centro
settentrionale dell'africa e il lago più
è il settimo lago più grande del mondo
il quarto in africa o forse dovremmo
dire era dal 1962 al 2014
la superficie del lago si è ridotta del
90 per cento principalmente a causa
della riduzione delle precipitazioni
indotte dal cambiamento climatico
dall'agricoltura intensiva dei sistemi
di irrigazione intorno a questa zona e
anche ovviamente la richiesta di acqua
dolce
come vedete nelle immagini nel 1973 il
bacino del lago era ancora abbastanza
ampio utilizzabile con delle risorse
nel 2001 il lago si era completamente
ristretto possiamo immaginare in che
condizioni sia oggi nel 2021 questo
impatto questo l'impatto ambientale
riguarda più di 40 milioni di persone
che vivono intorno a questa zona e
ritengono il lago come fonte principale
di sopravvivenza ma non solo
questa crisi sociale ambientale ed
economica ha fatto sì che si creassero
le condizioni perfette per la grazia di
conflitti armati
nel 2002 in questa zona è nato il gruppo
terroristico di boko haram il lago ciad
è un esempio di come tutto sia
interconnesso abbiamo visto che ci sono
fattori non solo ambientali ma anche
economici sociali culturali
facciamo parte di un grande ecosistema e
per questo abbiamo il dovere di guardare
con occhi diversi a questo problema
abbiamo bisogno di una visione di
insieme facciamo un passo indietro
immaginiamo di essere nelle nostre case
avvolti nella nostra quotidianità dei
nostri problemi
pensieri e visioni immaginiamo poi
riuscire a dare le spalle alla nostra
casa e guardarci intorno
vedremo altre case persone palazzi
negozi
immaginiamo che ci sia una montagna e di
poterci salire
arriviamo fino in cima poi fermiamoci
cosa vedete vedrete tutto vedrete il
panorama a 360 gradi
improvvisamente vi troverete circondati
immersi in quello che che vi circonda
ecco pensare al cambiamento climatico
solo come un problema ambientale
significa vedere
una parte dell'insieme la nostra piccola
casa andare sulla montagna scalare la
montagna vedere tutto il panorama
significa mettersi in relazione con
quello che ci circonda quindi con
l'ambiente le risorse naturali ma anche
quella società in generale con le altre
persone e significa prendersene cura
eppure non è stato così funzione siamo
presi cura così attentamente
abbiamo pensato in senso
individualistico abbiamo perso quello
che è il senso di collettività e oggi ci
troviamo a parlare di inclusione anche
verso il tema ambientale siamo nel 2021
ci sono tante sfide che ci aspettano
diritti delle donne discriminazioni
razziali di età di genere e di
orientamento sessuale
e a queste tante sfide per renderci
esseri umani migliori se n'è aggiunta
un'altra ancora più urgente il
cambiamento climatico ma se la nostra
casa brucia il nostro pianeta come dice
grattato un berg anche tutto il resto
non è possibile se vogliamo trasformare
il mondo così come lo conosciamo oggi
dobbiamo compiere una rivoluzione che
sia ambientale
ma è soprattutto culturale di pensiero
di modo di vedere il mondo di modo in
cui noi ci relazioniamo con il mondo
la complessità che ci richiede il
cambiamento climatico riguarda tutti
richiede l'impegno di tutti tutti noi
dobbiamo unire competenze conoscenze
esperienze per immaginare creare un
futuro diverso non riguarda più solo i
giovani e gli anziani le associazioni le
imprese e gli stati tutti noi dobbiamo
decidere di agire di andare in questa
direzione
essere leader di noi stessi e degli
altri con le nostre scelte
ricordo il momento in cui ho capito che
questa era questo era il mio campo di
battaglia dove cercare di portare avanti
quello in cui credo veramente
era il 2019 e organizzavo insieme
un gruppo di ragazzi di giovani la prima
local conference of youth on climate
change un evento supportato dalle
nazioni unite che precede i negoziati
sul clima a livello mondiale
grandissima opportunità e in questo
momento in quei giorni del 2019
abbiamo trattato diverse tematiche
legate al cambiamento climatico
soprattutto cercando di creare delle
proposte concrete da proporre poi alle
istituzioni locali nazionali ed
internazionali è stato quel momento in
cui eravamo tutti insieme uniti per una
causa comune
è lì che mi sono resa conto che un
problema così grande e così inarrivabile
era tangibile semplicemente con le
nostre azioni semplicemente unendosi con
chi crede nelle tue stesse cose nei tuoi
stessi ideali e quella energia
trasformatrice e continuate un po quella
che mi ha portato essere co oggi infatti
non mi sono fermata nel 2020 ha fondato
insieme a un altro gruppo di di giovani
un'associazione dedicata all'ambiente e
alla sostenibilità
cerchiamo di creare dialogo e valore
tale tra le realtà del territorio
diamo voce ad altri giovani come noi
perché è quindi insieme che possiamo
essere cambiamento
questo per me significa essere attivisti
essere attivi parte attiva nelle lotte
quotidiane credere in qualcosa cercare
di realizzarlo
siamo attivisti come individui ogni
volta che scegliamo cosa comprare dove
farlo siamo attivisti come collettività
ogni volta che partecipiamo a
un'attività sul nostro territorio la
pulizia di un fiume di una spiaggia di
un parco
stiamo attivisti ogni volta che
scegliamo di informarci un po di più e
poi decidiamo di cambiare il nostro modo
di agire nelle nostre vite
in questo periodo più che mai ci siamo
resi conto che qualcosa che accade anche
dall'altra parte del mondo ha un effetto
sulla nostra vita
oggi più che mai il pianeta la terra è
stato visto come un unità
il cambiamento climatico può essere
visto come la più grande catastrofe che
ci aspetta oppure come la più grande
occasione che abbiamo come esseri umani
come umanità di andare in una direzione
diversa
insieme a cooperare insieme io sono
sempre stata guidata dalla convinzione
che ci fosse sempre un'alternativa ai
nostri pensieri e le nostre emozioni ai
nostri problemi
e questa alternativa c'è oggi c'è
l'abbiamo perché dipende da noi
noi siamo che scegliamo di essere siamo
le battaglie che combattiamo siamo le
relazioni che coltiviamo stiamo la cura
che mettiamo nel innaffiare le piante
siamo l'aria salmastra e riva al mare
siamo la corteccia degli alberi
stiamo la passione che mettiamo nel
raggiungere i nostri sogni
noi e gli altri noi ed il pianeta stiamo
la stessa cosa
l'ambiente sono io sei tu siamo noi
grazie
[Applauso]